brain plasticity or neuroplasticity
describes our brain's ability to grow
and change in response to the way we use
it just like a muscle our brain can grow
and change and get stronger it's
constantly changing either getting
better or getting weaker depending on
how often and how well you use it when
you think about it this is one of the
most important abilities of the brain in
many ways it correlates directly with
intelligence with our ability to train
and improve in a particular skill by
thickening and increasing the size of
the respective brain areas but also to
improve the communication between the
brain areas so that we can use whole
brain thinking many ways this is the key
to unlock all other cognitive abilities
whether it's improving our eyesight
whether it's improving our memory
whether it's helping us to speak more
fluently whether it's to help us learn
new languages or new skills brain
plasticity in many ways is the ultimate
biohack and if you could tap into the
true plastic potential of your brain
then in theory you could ultimately
completely redesign your brain to work
the way you wanted to you could gain
entirely new skills and you could change
the very way you think want to become
ambidextrous plasticity makes it
possible gain perfect pitch that might
be possible to increase your corpus
callosum to increase the communication
between your two brain hemispheres so
your brain works more like Einsteins
there's not necessarily off the table a
good place to start would be to describe
how brain plasticity works in the first
place so if you recall your brain is
made up of billions of neurons which are
brain cells that each connect to each
other in a huge network each neuron is
made up of a nucleus which houses the
DNA as well as dendrites which reach out
like tendrils across the brain to
communicate with other neurons then you
have the axon the long tail which ends
in the axon terminal which releases
action potentials signals so that they
can be passed on to the dendrites of
other neurons the postsynaptic neurons
via a synapse which is a gap which acts
like a bridge a synapse is essentially a
connection between any two neurons
whenever you experience anything when
you remember something when you see
something when you feel something any
kind of qualia this corresponds to the
firing of a neuron in your brain if you
were to it
quickly stimulate specific neurons using
an electrode then you could cause dots
of light to appear in your vision or you
could trigger dormant memories so the
action potential is the electric impulse
that travels through the nerve when it
fires and this then is passed on to the
next neuron that's connected to that
neuron and if the excitation is enough
this will cause the other neuron to fire
so brain plasticity occurs when new
dendrites form when axons lengthen and
thicken and when you sign APS's form new
connections between nearby neurons and
the mantra which is often repeated to
understand how this works is that
neurons that fire together wire together
so in other words if two neurons
repeatedly fire at the same time then
eventually the axons and dendrites will
reach out form a new sign apps a new
connection and then from then on when
one of those neurons fires the other
will be more likely to fire once it
passes a certain threshold so with
intentional practice and repetition we
can form new connections and then
strengthen them over time through a
process called long term potentiation
long term potentiation basically means
that the connection the synapse gets
stronger and more likely to fire this
occurs via glutamate receptors called
ampa and nmda so glutamate is the main
excitatory neurotransmitter in the brain
it's a chemical that's released that
makes a neuron more likely to fire more
sensitive to input from other neurons so
as the number of receptors the glutamate
increases over time that neuron becomes
more likely to fire from that input the
presynaptic neuron becomes more likely
to trigger the firing of the
postsynaptic neuron this process
basically means that through deliberate
practice by constantly repeating the
same actions the same sequence of
actions you can cement that sequence and
thereby make it much easier to retrieve
that information next time or to perform
the exact same movement or to remember a
song or a rhyme or fact because you've
linked them to existing stronger
connections other mechanisms that are
responsible for break last ISTE include
myelination of the axons this means that
a protective sheath an insulating sheath
is added to the long tails of the
neurons over time to make them stronger
and to make the signal travel faster
through them at the same time
neurogenesis means the birth of new
neurons but just as important is
Natick elimination or synaptic pruning
and basically this means the removal of
synapse is the removal of unwanted
defunct connections this is actually
just as important as the creation of new
ones and occurs via a process called LD
P or long term depression so in other
words it's just as important to remove
the unnecessary unwanted connections is
to build the new better one so it's not
all about growth is also about
efficiency so if we could make all of
these things happen more often and to a
greater extent and in theory it would
become easier to learn any new subject
and you new facts any new skills to lay
down spatial memories to gain new
physical skills and potentially like I
say to even change the way you think to
remove negative thought patterns for
instance so how do we increase
neuroplasticity
well neuroplasticity is modulated by
several neurotransmitters and this might
be a good place to start
neurotransmitters of course being the
chemicals that are released at the same
time as the action potentials when
neurons communicate these chemicals
include things like serotonin of
filtered hormone melatonin in the sleep
in your transmitter dopamine the focus
new transmitter so BDNF aids the
survival of synapse ah's and neurons and
it also encourages the formation of new
dendrites and new synapses synaptic
Genesis so this encourages the brain to
reach out and form more connections and
it strengthens those connections that
already exist
nerve growth factor seems to act in
similar ways and also increases
long-distance communication between
neurons so that two distant neurons that
fire over and over at the same time will
eventually begin to wire together
dopamine also plays a role and is
closely linked to BDNF although the
exact nature of this link isn't fully
understood when you raise BDNF your
surace dopamine and the reverse also
appears to be true so dopamine is often
referred to as the reward hormone
because it seems to be produced at times
when we're working towards a reward so
when you're doing something the brain
thinks is worthwhile that requires your
focus because it thinks you're going to
be benefited in the long term you
produce dopamine this doesn't just mean
working towards a goal it also means
things like playing computer game
because you're learning the brain likes
it when your performance improves this
is a rewarding activity thus you produce
them all the dopamine you focus more and
this
also increases more BDNF and dopamine is
also often released at the same time as
adrenaline and other fight-or-flight
neurotransmitters because it helps us to
focus more and to record what's
happening so in other words when
something important is happening our
attention is directed in that way we're
more likely to focus we're more like to
feel motivated and at the same time
plasticity increases in the brain in
order to help us learn those behaviors
and save them so that we can refer to
that information
in future so one of the best ways to
improve plasticity in any given task is
to make sure that you intrinsically find
it rewarding that you properly engaged
and that you're not just doing it on the
side because you have to if you're fully
focused if you're fully motivated you
will learn better than if you're not and
this is something that I talk about a
lot in this channel and in future I'll
talk about how you can improve that with
CBT cognitive behavioral therapy but
obviously this being the binary you
might now be wondering whether there's a
way you can increase the production of
these neurotransmitters through the use
of nootropics and as it happens there
are several nootropics that will do this
for you for instance coffee bean extract
has recently been found to increase
levels of BDNF brain-derived
neurotrophic factor this is included in
a new product from bulletproof who also
make bulletproof coffee called neuro
master they actually sent me a copy of
not copy
they sent me a tub of neuro masseter of
you paid me to review it and i reviewed
it and it was a relatively positive
review and then they said don't worry
about publishing that review so that was
very weird but according to the research
coffee bean extract does increase brain
plasticity via the production of BDNF
however if you read to the study closely
it does say something along the lines of
maybe even as much as caffeine so that's
to say that it's not orders of magnitude
in terms of the improvement it's a mild
improvement seeing as it's not that much
greater than caffeine anyways so
caffeine also is something you can use
to increase your plasticity after all it
does increase dopamine so it makes a lot
of sense and it increases focus neuro
Master did include a combination of
coffee bean extract and caffeine and
personally whilst I used it I actually
thought it's really good
and over time I found myself using the
whole two tubs they sent me even though
I had no commitment to do so at that
point that's always a sign it's very
hard to rule out placebo in these sorts
of cases so I can't say for sure whether
or not that's what was going on there
but I would say it felt like it had some
kind of effect to the point that I found
myself want to take it most days
basically on the days when I took it I
found that I was more productive and
focused than on the days when I didn't
and that's the great thing to bear in
mind about BDNF and brain plasticity is
that it doesn't just increase your
ability to retain information and store
facts it also helps you to focus more
and to feel more motivated because as I
said BD net is tied to dopamine so to me
this is one of the safer ways to
increase focus without stimulating
yourself without causing the
fight-or-flight response via the use of
things like caffeine or modafinil I
think this is a gentler and safer way to
increase your focus Oh
one serious downside to neuro Master is
that is prohibitively expensive I did
give this kind of balanced review in the
video so maybe that's why they didn't
want me to publish it who knows another
one is forskolin which is also used in
sill tech that's a very popular long
term potentiation stack that all Caesars
artichoke extract this helps to increase
gene expression thereby allowing the
nerves and the neurons to change to grow
those extra receptors that they need and
in theory this can support brain
plasticity in an entirely different way
and a lot of people have a lot of luck
with it
I found sill tip similar to neuro Master
it kind of gave me a bit more focus I
felt it could have been a placebo
possibly to a slightly lesser extent in
my case but there's a review of still
tip on my website I've talked about
forskolin a little bit so head over
there to get more information on that
another good one is magnesium three and
eight - magnesium in general is very
good for brain plasticity it helps to
protect the neurons and the synapse is
especially during sleep and to relax the
brain magnesium three and eight is
particularly bioavailable especially for
the brain and has been shown in some
studies to be potentially useful for
learning and memory then there's lion's
mane which increases nerve growth factor
production and if you were to take this
along with some of the others on this
list then you've got kind of multi
from the tack therefore your brain
plasticity so whilst each of them only
has a slight effect maybe if you combine
all of them it would have a more
noticeable effect there's lots of stacks
out there which combine things like this
together in order to get those kinds of
results omega-3 fatty acid is useful for
myelination that coating of the axons
will help to strengthen neurons I've
talked on the website about how omega-3
fatty acid does pretty much everything
and for the price and the availability
there's not really any reason not to be
using it turmeric is also said to be
good and I'll leave a bigger list a
nootropic stack for enhancing plasticity
on the website so check out the link to
the description down below always do
that if I recommend it if you want the
full experience I liken this to going to
watch a movie and then reading these
supplementary comic you don't need to do
it but it will add to your experience
and give me the full story the same goes
for my social media channels we can
often see me working on these things
behind the scenes like I say there all
of these things are gonna marginally
increase your neuroplasticity you're not
gonna overnight to turn into a learning
genius however one of the most
interesting pieces of research was
looking at a substance called about pro8
and this was shown to be able to
increase plasticity to the extent that
full-grown adults were able to learn
perfect pitch which means that they can
identify a pitch and correctly named it
as a B D F sharp and being able to do
that suggests that their brain
plasticity has just been restored almost
to the point that it was at as a child
so this is very interesting however I
don't recommend that you use valproate
because unfortunately it's also liver
toxic and has a number of unwanted side
effects but it's certainly very
interesting nonetheless another more out
layer method you can use in order to
increase brain plasticity is something
called tDCS or transcranial direct
current stimulation and this means that
you're running small electric currents
through your brain and yes it does sound
completely insane but there's actually
commercial products available that allow
you to do this so the idea here is that
the electric charge is very small it's
not enough to force your neurons to fire
that's electro convulsion therapy very
different not recommended rather you're
just increasing the excitability of the
neurons therefore making them more
likely to fire and making them more
plastic and this excitability continues
even after you stop the application of
that current and it lasts for about half
an hour afterwards what's interesting
about TV
ECS is that you're affecting specific
areas of the brain so you might do it
specifically to the motor cortex or the
prefrontal cortex or some other area of
your brain there's particular montages
which means they show you the placement
of 'we should put the anode and the
cathode on your body then on your skull
and by doing this you can replicate the
studies found the findings found in
various studies DARPA has a accelerated
learning montage for instance which
includes putting the one pad on your
right temple and the other one on your
left shoulder and there's some
incredible studies looking at how this
work don't seem to be any negative side
effects and people learn all sorts of
skills more rapidly and it's something
that I say DARP is looking into so it's
obviously some interest there and like I
say this commercial products available
to allow you to do this as something
called halo which is used for athletes
you wear on your head and it stimulates
the motor cortex in theory to help you
learn movement patterns more quickly
then there's the focus which is a device
you're on your head for gaming in order
to increase your reaction times and your
focus and to help you to learn those
things more quickly over time for
competitive gamers of course each one of
these ribs makes us stronger faster more
skilled and you can also make this sort
of thing at home and many biohackers
will put things together involving pads
and small electric charges that they
then share the blueprints for or sell
for small price and you can find these
online
I've tried one out and yeah it feels
weird
so don't recommend this one for I can't
say that I really do and the reason is
that a we don't know the long term side
effects even though there's no
short-term negative side effects that
we're aware of and at the same time
there is such thing as negative
plasticity and negative plasticity is
brain custody that you don't want you
see if you increase your brain
plasticity you can pick up new skills
you can develop positive habits you can
change your way of thinking and expand
your mind and you could also pick up a
bad habit or you could cement a really
painful memory and just the same as it's
easy to learn good things that's also
being used to learn bad things that is
negative plasticity this could be how
phobias come about for instance because
you're creating association that doesn't
need to exist
something harmless and a very frightened
response in much the same way that an
allergy works but for the brain like a
brain allergy
that's a cool analogy I have gone way
off track anyways there's such a thing
as negative plasticity and this is a
threat whenever you do anything to try
and crease your brain plasticity but I
wouldn't worry about it too much because
the brain has very powerful mechanisms
in order to help you know what's good
and what you want to enforce and know
what's bad this is why we get so
frustrated when we fumble and we get
that sense of victory when we
successfully do something we're trying
to do this is our brain reinforcing its
own behavior I talked about this in my
video on visualization training how we
visualize what we're going to do then
perform it and if the action matches the
visualization it's reinforced however in
the case of something like tDCS what
you're doing is you're increasing the
excitability of a whole brain area kind
of without that oversight so you're
increasing plasticity across the whole
area reinforcing everything that you do
in theory and what's more is that you
could place these pads in the wrong
places you might inaccurately try to
copy the montage and end up stimulating
the wrong areas of the brain this is
very possible when you consider as well
that our brains are so different like I
was saying Einstein had a larger corpus
callosum the band of neurons that
connect the two hemispheres and so if
you're placing your pads in these kind
of predefined positions based on
something you read you might not
actually be stimulating the right brain
areas you might be strengthening
connections that you don't want to
connect to strengthen and therefore
causing negative plasticity and also
whenever you buy a device to electrocute
your brain off of the web you know you
get what you get really you'll get what
you're asked for so I'm not saying
completely don't do it it is interesting
and some people have had a lot of luck
with this for treating things like
depression however I recommend you speak
to a doctor about that and for most
people other than the hardcore bio
hackers I wouldn't recommend tinkering
with that one in particular so there's
actually a good reason for our brain
plasticity to be limited in the way it
is because if you gave it complete free
rein to adapt to everything that happens
it wouldn't necessarily always be
positive and in fact the brain produces
chemicals
specifically to suppress brain
plasticity these include things like
HDAC and that's why bowel crave works
because evaporate is a HDAC inhibitor so
you could say that really our brain is
plastic enough and certainly we can make
it as plastic as we need it to be
through different lifestyle changes and
that's probably the most interesting
Avenue for increasing plasticity so
there's a few of the obvious lifestyle
changes that will improve your
plasticity as usual exercise proves to
be fantastic especially for hippocampal
plasticity increases the rethus of
dopamine and B D and F so it's no
surprise that this happens and my theory
for that is that when you exercise when
you use your body when you move you are
of course learning that movement every
time you lift a weight every time you
kick a football every time you go for a
walk or a run your body is still
learning still refining that movement to
reduce the likelihood of you tripping or
falling so every time you do that you're
learning and the brain rewards itself
and this is why it likes us exercising
so much it loves learning the brain
loves learning computer games at the
same time could definitely increase
basicity and it has been shown to boost
the size of various brain areas by doing
this again when you play a computer game
you're learning you're deciding what you
want to do you're learning new motor
skills new inputs at the same time
you're figuring out the new rules of
that game and you're testing your
reactions and that's why computer games
are so addictive as I've said before
because you get that rush of positive
new transmitters every time you complete
the goal and when you don't you feel
frustrated you want to try again and
refine those neural connections so
moving more exercising more and playing
computer games could help you to improve
your plasticity at the same time stress
is very negative for plasticity and can
actually cause cortical pruning and
elimination the bad kind so reducing
stress is important for boosting
plasticity meditation has been shown to
increase gray matter across the board
and connectivity whole brain
connectivity so that could be very
useful for increasing plasticity and of
course fighting stress and sleep as
you'd expect is also incredibly
important when you sleep this is when
the brain will replay many of the things
that learned during the day and actually
reinforce those neural connections
you're sleeping but really what's the
most important of all is just that we
keep learning keep challenging the brain
things like chess have been shown to
improve plasticity but that's not
because chess is somehow magical is just
because it forces us to use our brain
and when you learn any subject in
creature plasticity if you learn a new
language if you learn to play a new
instrument these are fantastic things to
do for plasticity and really if we want
to see an example of song with
superhuman plasticity you just have to
look at a baby for a long time
scientists taught the plasticity didn't
occur in adults and only occurred during
our early development and the reason for
this is that babies and very young
children infants their plasticity is
off-the-charts their brain can adapt so
quickly to new information this is why
we say an old dog can't learn new tricks
cuz compared to a baby that's learning
to walk learning to speak learning to
understand the world around it well they
really can't they used to think that
there was a kind of critical period
during which you can learn and after
that the brain was set we now know this
isn't true but our learning is slower
and far less plastic as compared to the
way it was when we were younger and the
theory is still that this is a kind of
age-related switch off point so once you
get to a certain age the neuro chemicals
change and you're less like to learn new
things what we know is that the more you
learn the more you produce BDNF and
dopamine etc the more interesting things
you take on the more plastic your brain
becomes so could it not be that the
reason that we become less plastic as we
age is not because we're getting older
but because we're learning less when
you're an infant you're learning in an
completely in a way that we can't even
imagine because imagine being born into
a world but you don't understand
anything about it it's not just that you
don't know what does that do you don't
even know what that is you don't know
what color is you know what shapes are
you don't know what gravity is you don't
know how to move your own arms they're
learning literally everything from
scratch and so it could be this learning
that causes the cascade of plasticity
that enables them to learn it's just
again specific adaptations to impose
demands if you want to get more plastic
use your plasticity if you want to get
better at learning use that learning as
we get older we continue to learn things
at school we learn things like how to
drive we learn how to interact with
other people but then we find our way
into a job we get into a rut and we stop
learning as much
stop going outside as much because we
don't have to we sit at a computer all
day we interacted the same people we've
known all the time we become set in our
ways and it's at this point that we
start to find ourselves in danger of
various needed gentle Euro dedenne neuro
degenerative diseases because we're not
using our brain anymore
and it's become far less plastic and as
we get older and older we also injure
ourselves to find it harder to move
around people we know die we interact
with people less up days become far more
routine and the more routine your date
becomes the lesson like change and
difference so our brains become less and
less plastic but if we were to learn
again and to encourage ourselves to
learn new things new topics then we
could increase that plasticity again
whether it's learning movement patterns
by taking up dance or martial arts
whether it's increasing our knowledge by
reading books or whether it's gaining
new skills like new languages we could
then tap into greater plasticity and the
more you learn the better you'll become
at learning and perhaps someday we'll be
able to recreate the conditions that we
experience as a child through virtual
reality because through virtual reality
you could change almost all of your
inputs you could create a world that's
completely fun and force yourself to
learn how to navigate through it learn
you teach yourself to navigate in new
ways
games that force us to move around by
using your hands these for example
teach you an entirely new form of
movement that actually uses your limbs
rather than just buttons and if you have
to learn new rules and things in theory
we could subject ourselves to a kind of
intensive multi-sensory learning for a
short period of time in order to become
better at learning other things
throughout the day but that's just a
theory a brain theory at the end of the
day the most important thing you should
be doing is staying active with your
learning and continuously pushing
yourself and learning new things the
internet makes this more possible than
it's ever been there's nothing to stop
you learning to program learning 3d
modeling learning video editing learning
new subjects learning history languages
instruments learning martial arts yoga
so don't sit on your roles don't rest on
your levels keep growing and adapting
just like your body your brain is
changing all the time that's
non-negotiable
and the only thing you
can decide as whether it's getting
better or getting worse so keep active
use it or lose it
so found this video useful interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
please share around that helps me
immensely comment down below and let me
know what you think did I miss anything
have you found any cool research on
brain plasticity lately let me know what
topics you'd like me to cover in the
future
I've got tons coming to the channel soon
I'm doing a video on zombie apocalypse
training I'm doing a video on tendon
strength and on neck strength one on
calisthenics I've got more stuff I'm
working on line coming so if that all
sounds good then hit the notification
button in order to get notifications
subscribe to the channel and stick
around for next time and I'll see you
then
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now
[Music]